oops hello guys welcome to this
broadcast yeah I should have really
started with the with this screen but I
didn't oh let's get right into the
action okay ready for a couple of
five-minute games and yeah looking
forward to a couple of those tough
opponents yeah okay I'm going to request
a five-minute game and game started you
you you will be thrilled to see my
rating I hope 2500 oh six so when I've
scored quite a bit in recent games let's
see if I can keep this rating in this
session which would be pretty cool so
I've got a mainline chick arena playing
my old line he has to have some some
positive feelings about that
yeah I had a good - had a good one I
really had a good run going up to 2500
again
so we have this very closed position
yeah that I've had around a million
times in blitz let's see what happens
Yama autumn is to 5:30 or something like
that so we closed down close down the
Queen side yeah yeah sure I will upload
those videos I had a this this is going
to be up and next week or so I've
pre-recorded quite a bit um okay
interesting here 95 as an idea 95 he
will just go back I can so test it a
little bit maybe he wants to take would
be strange though not 91 or night you
wanna stir normal the normal move here
and this position is very closed maybe I
should have played the brayer or
something but this is this is what it is
you're often yeah hindsight is 20/20
yeah why just should move the night to e
1 norm to G 1 taking it I think is
rather nice for black so we found it I
mean not not difficult but still so what
you do here sometimes you can go H 5 but
not easy to do they could go h4 h5 here
a rook to f8 would be good something
like that okay I'll do I go here
is he going f4 maybe yeah Ukraine beat
Russia today and Olympiad it's very
tough also for the Russian team there
was other teams Ukraine strong
personally I think that the the Chinese
team is extremely strong okay I'm
pushing f5 now what would you play for
black against 503 in the bank or gambit
I can give you a very clear answer to
that in roughly a week because I'm
working on a black repertoire in the
Banco to be released on a website and
this is on my list of things to check ok
so this is getting very very complex now
now it to probably sf4 but I'm going
here
tough tough position here Bishop g5 I
don't know if this is a good idea but
I've threatened to take and go Queen h4
mate
so maybe
the best answer to defy all that stuff
you can play many things there is no
clean clean clear answer to that yeah F
form this is an interesting choice if I
take yeah I probably have to take some
stuff coming to g6 but 95 g4 is also
part of this and I'm a little bit ahead
on the clock a little bit ahead on the
clock him night at 495 threatens mmm I
can't go 95 here anyway if he takes it
this night of three let's do it
not totally sure what is this decision
though I mean is it good is it good as
the thing I'm not losing material but
I'm not quite sure about the objective
merit here check
mm Joe Queen takes Knight takes not sure
him I think I'll should take me the
Queen this is kind of hanging but that's
a strong mover that's a strong move
96 is just coming here
rook f6 h6 not sure doesn't look good
at least it's a little trick now 96
doesn't work but something like rook
aged 2 is probably not bad when he
played that valium
I could go creature fire but this is
just a transposition earlier I'm not
playing the Halloween game better and
I'm not going to play the Grove I'm
sorry I don't play crap okay so at least
I get to trade some stuff here okay I'm
kind of happy that I can trade some
stuff out it still doesn't look all that
great check my knight back here still
suffering
still suffering here check
yeah the group is just just said
completely incorrect opening so it's
really no big incentive to play it
Leningrad Dutch yeah this is this is
kinda became but I will play the Banco
for some excitement but first of all I
have to survive this game which will be
difficult
he wants to bring this around to e4 but
okay I can go here what is he going out
going here a knight okay let's bring
this okay time warning hmm I cannot take
this unfortunately in 98 is very passive
hmm
my d8 is extremely passive but maybe
still I'm trying for h4 and King me five
stuff let's see I mean I'm ahead on the
clock here which is something
I can take with the other one I think
I've tricked him and yeah and I've
tricked him
check check check check
white for fits on time
whoo okay I'm not playing the leather
elephant camp it okay so that was a win
the tough one yeah I think he basically
had outplayed me at some point look very
very difficult okay let's go for a new
game yeah the bank oh this kind of
borderline certainty on the top level
yes they don't like to be worn down but
I'm currently studying in a bit and I
think on a on a normal kind of level
especially on a club level or let's say
something that is 2200 whatever it's
very very it's very very playable
especially in Krypton controls it takes
a moment at the wild to get your games
because many people are at the loop yet
and makes it difficult or a little bit
slower to get games ok playing Killian
here
my opponents where I usually struggle
I've got a 50% score against him 19
that's really crazy nineteen point five
out of 39 so exactly 50% yeah I think
the Banco is very very valid on this
kind of slightly below GM level because
it is such an active opening this is
really a very important and is in blitz
chest you can play it on almost any
level III maybe I should have taken once
I was thinking III at four but night age
five he could have things going for him
on the dark squares
I won't see he 3 is is the rules okay me
I don't have to play a for it's kind of
the knee-jerk reaction but I don't have
to I can also let him take kind of
interesting that he it takes time III
looks like the absolutely obvious move
oh hi this is a nice ending okay not not
wasting any time here with this I'm just
better in this ending a little bit at
least
yeah I'm after non-alcoholic beer try to
be a little bit healthy and that regard
okay so I've got the bishop area I would
like to play rook c1 and get rid of his
his rook but he might take play Bishop
takes or something on default what am I
doing here
mm-hmm rook d1 another idea is a group
d1 bishop a1 and move the knight
okay he's taking some time to just kind
of nice to see okay I'm just covering
b3m
okay so age five okay
I'm going here so that the bishop is not
hanging Oh
so hmm if I take it not sure that this
really helps if I take I wanted to go
Knight d5 was my idea I take it okay a
gem it's not doing much might be five
the spots potentially whoops and then I
can take anyway I think it looks like a
good move how long did it take for me to
get rid of the nicotine obsession Wow
really really happy that this this is
long gone
yeah always gotta look see - I forgot
about that idea entirely oh my god
okay who probably have to take all kinds
of stuff to avoid an immediate disaster
okay so of course I cannot take him can
take a for me yeah let's do it
yeah it took a while I actually switched
from nicotine from from tobacco to those
electric cigarettes and from from those
I went to yeah not not not at all
it is something that worked for me it
does not have to work for everybody of
course but for me it was was a good way
of doing it it worked
at least okay so check check check
cheeky take be seven at the end miss age
five something don't know where I think
I'll grab this first time yeah a poor
structure is not all that great but part
of the pawn structure is also having an
extra pawn and I have one actually have
to which it's not not that fantastic
so it's age five something here age five
a bishop age four is actually attacking
this
hmm that's not great h5 you might have
Bishop h4 immediately hmm that's not
good whoo I don't see a clear way here
to to not get into trouble
sure h4 this is a big issue I didn't see
something good him
you had the chef - so Wow g7 it's that I
can't go g7 here
mmm he doesn't have something fantastic
snot
my room is hanging my rook is hanging I
didn't see that at all but okay it
doesn't doesn't really it's not it's not
fatal but Time Warner I just did not see
that F for this episode 96 check could
be oh no I can take that now that was
very lucky in the lack resins that was
some kind of mouse slip whoo okay Wow
yeah I don't do much analysis here but
that was much to look at and certainly
should keep some kind of an advantage
but I didn't get it I didn't didn't see
how okay who knew game 2 5 2 4 so it's
actually time to have a quick look at
the all-time high two five three sevens
over 13 points 13 points short
yeah so when am I going to get I didn't
see those games today at the Olympiad I
just see the results there India won
okay India's India's team is also pretty
strong if we she would play I think
there would be real contenders for
medals really strong team Hari Krishna
is very strong re-bond we did this with
Rahman they are very very strong Germany
today also won I think they won three
bomb again one it's a very good German
junior player or make like 21 or
something it's not technically a junior
maybe yeah David smiled and drew Magnus
it was was cool for David for sure so
let's see I'm requesting a game but I
don't get one it's seems tough yeah it's
it's fun to get to get to the to the
highest rating my all-time high I had an
April this year so it's okay yeah
everybody had her and had a good idea
started don't look at a game against
guilt okay
I'll stick with my English opening
Reggie stuff and scoring really like you
like a madman with it okay so net watch
as opposed to the tower mr. Gil
I'm actually not playing that if I
wasn't a Stig I mean not a mistake
technically speaking but I don't know
this line now shoot okay I focus I have
to focus here because otherwise I can
get into trouble yeah I have a play
different line but I forgot about it
night if was not what I did what I
studied more for your town who was the
better attacker there that's tough today
they really lived and lived at different
times so I think yeah Todd certainly had
tougher opposition so maybe Tom but
those kind of discussions are always
very difficult to do yeah I'm under some
pressure here
there is some this Cashin going on here
about various drugs in the German kind
of on a decent level my take is that
yeah I tend to avoid everything I did
smoked for quite a while which was not a
good idea ever and I'm happy that I'm
off that and the only thing I do
nowadays is to drink the odd beer or
glass of wine or something but it's not
it's not very frequent even yeah so yeah
I don't know maybe there are not that
many and there are a couple of strong
players around only gas is actually
around so it could happen that I played
them it's not totally out of the out of
the picture okay so what am I doing here
yeah it's very tough I have to have to
grab this I guess Bishop takes and then
Bishop d3 or something rook to e8 Bishop
d3 not happy here that it looks kind of
playable
okay so this is hanging p3 is also
hanging
yeah this is not good here I don't like
this position at all and it's also
objectively not good him the only thing
is I met on the clock which is might be
helpful yeah yeah that will be I mean
winning is very difficult okay um Bishop
Jake's maybe here come on I've heard he
offers me a draw yeah I should take this
normally but it's a very very weak move
to offer draw him it's a little bit like
checking in poker if you have a have a
better position offering a draw I mean I
don't think I'm necessarily losing here
because of my my own my activity but
okay Bishop here I can also go okay five
night to you for somebody wants to play
can I go here it doesn't have a good
discovery I think I declined the drop
because I thought I might get get the
pawn back like here and then actually
end up in the better end endgame this is
a little bit better for white now so um
Bishop where maybe here control the
knight in control I could have taken it
I could have taken it why did that take
it
Wow Wow
oh my goodness I could have just taken
the Devon white and would have made
things quite a bit easier quite a bit
okay the Knights - doesn't have many
squares but I could have just taken it
out laughs yeah he doesn't really have a
good move here we can go here then
deform okay let's go for the next game
so um yeah if you have a good run you
you often just have this those lucky
moments so if you idiot check my history
it's like it's all pluses I had one one
loss today and here's some loss but it
really was a fantastic run okay so let's
see what what happens I forgot a new
request Wow
there are a couple of strong guys around
but one thing is I mean people playing
the limp here they sometimes welcome to
the ICC to check games or to share
boards this also happens gain started
roomie lives okay I hope actually that
he dies in this game it's a ok so now I
have six services don't not default
please okay this is equally boring
this is equally boring there should be
six okay okay let's do this and hope
that it's not oh what's that
yeah the the Spanish four nights is
really one of the most boring openings
and shares 95 never saw that one so
let's see here okay so here I just want
to trade stuff yeah Jack Age 3 okay that
that doesn't look very threatening I
have not canceled Schwarz oh I might be
able to go for non castles he will go
Bishop e3 here
I might want to play Bishop c3 here
Bishop c3 okay I can still do that
yeah I've got a good bind in the center
him h5 gain some space is he going f4
here maybe I have a go g5 I will just go
g5 here right grab space
and the d6 bishop is not a pawn this six
bishop is strong yeah this is
interesting this this Knight doesn't
have squares which does not mean that
it's necessarily fantastic for me but it
doesn't have squares so there is stuff
going on here with f6 Queen g6 takes
takes a threat and f6 let's see the
final suits run probably working final
super song is regular viewer so f6 I try
to trap the night that was the idea of
this whole thing let's see if I can do
it
f6 trapping the night how is he saving
this piece
it's there's some tactic I don't see it
at the moon I think f6v windows annoyed
I think I win it let's see so I have sex
right okay so after I take here he wants
to take a five hmm that's not a big
issue actually I'll check in on g5 Queen
takes Bishop tonight five four seven so
that's it hmm I don't know I was
surprising her how quickly that went
downhill
probably this Knight to g5 didn't work I
think it maybe didn't work okay and I
don't analyze here so let's get going to
five three four set the all-time high
no three seven so I need to win one more
one more game one more game
basically any game does
yeah that's a very good session but I'm
somehow in good shape 3 points to 537 is
the autumn home game start so if I'm
winning this game against Rene 64 this
would be a banker I think he plays
uniform he doesn't okay I think I had a
bank over against him in an earlier game
some some days ago yeah I get this line
but for important games and let's I
still rely on that an important thing is
I can play very quickly and still people
tend to not play it all that well yeah
that that is that that's about what
everybody knows so let's see
a difference between this and the game
before is that the a file is open okay
since it's going for a quick fom
certainly certainly possible
okay so Bishop here that g7 okayed in
this kind of position if I get the rooks
traded I'm usually okay okay just take
them and I think I'll just take with
this I'm not sure here he it feels like
he's not entirely not that well set up
here I can also go Bishop h4 here which
is kind of unusual and this is a
possibility hmm
oh I'm sure this is a very tough
decision if I do this could easily be
wrong the wrong decision might have six
I don't know okay let's go here tough
tough situation look at four is an
interesting idea
Angela I think I'm okay yeah nothing
special but it's okay what's the deal
here
okay idea save age five which she does
not react to maybe he doesn't have to
react to it I can also bring the bishop
around once also an idea and not sure
let's take that first and then maybe
it's now five what's happening after
that my tics okay let's go age five so
it's not all that clear
twenty eight
I can take here Knight takes Knight h5
and interesting he takes with the pawn
okay so over to f6 Knight f3 I will grab
G form tough there's a knight f6 good
here why isn't that good
Queen h3 maybe
Knight f6 screen age 3 I can go g5
you'll have to swing the rock over
somehow that would be really cool night
age seven for Bishop g5 may be tough I
went down to 113 spend too much time
here spend too much time he wants to
take in Queen age six okay I have to
slow him let's speed up
yeah
the last couple of moves were not
exactly in my favor quite obviously I
got really good nervous noticing that
the time that the time went to went down
and that much time warning damn it
I had a really good position at one
point but I can just take CA - I never
shoot check ah of course
- that wasn't born a chance I mean round
around here and widest I think black is
very okay I cannot believe I'm Lewis him
I actually should be better but maybe
not you know the engine is always a is
equal to shell that's very tough okay
let's not be too upset about it and see
I was really tough somewhere out here
must have been okay I'm pretty sure this
isn't that good food lucky I mean I have
a hard time to believe in that for wild
but it's very difficult to play so it's
very tough to claim also it was I should
have maybe maybe I should have stayed a
bit longer there
maybe I should have just done what I
usually do like trade the rocks yeah
that's probably better with hindsight I
should have probably traded the ropes
down yeah I think that's better yeah
okay I could have gotten easier rating
but and an easy opponent yeah but that's
it should that's for sure but I think
I'm still the favorite in this game
anyway so whatever yeah this is better I
have to get rid of the rooks so I've
ever repressed out it's the first loss
after quite a good one okay gained
started a grandmaster tactical so let's
see what he does the symmetrical defense
yeah this is an extremely extremely
solid setup for black where white
doesn't get any advantage objectively
but what usually gets on what usually
get some someone interesting position
still night eight five hmm
it's not that idea usually I would like
to answer this move with afore not
trading so much I came so I don't like
this so much but okay it's it's playable
for my dogs them but not great
I could play before b5 I think I'll go
for that
94 is nice and four wide and here he at
least has his night somewhat somewhat
misplaced okay so he seeks something
like that he's 65 22 I've loose an
exchange so let's not do that so to
prevent e5 I actually have to do this
and take this just not not really great
but I think I needed to prevent u5 in
here and this is my distance somewhat
offside so Air Force the ambitious
ambitious move
9334 is something I never bet school
against this player by the way usually
not going all that well against him I
don't have a good spot for the King here
would like to bring a knight to f3 my
King f2 looks totally wrong okay maybe I
can do this tempt him into a queen b7 I
go King age 3
I don't think chance this is all that
great for black I mean not that is wrong
or bad or anything but it maybe looks
better than it actually is now I get
this regrouping
yeah the next the night is again running
around jumping around rather jump around
yeah he wants to go efore and undermine
c4 yeah still I have to I'm not sure how
clear this actually is to be honest I
think the trend is not exactly against
me
let's see every Minister goes in for
it just takes it yeah okay this is this
is I think clearly stronger than
recapturing so no point in taking a long
time here
I need to play against his weaknesses
here F pawan and so on the ending is
very okay actually 96 check would be
part of it could be part of it so what
is he going to do here I don't know I go
here 96 check rock takes a 5 no I'm fine
yeah I think you find him
hmm didn't think about that at all I can
I can take now a couple of times there
take take takes King edge 7 look at 5 2
into C 1 maybe but I can just type let's
just play simple Chang this is just a
better position with no big difficulties
I think so I can take here now say
anything better and probably not time
wanted anything better than that
not sure on it i Scott rook g8g
and okay and I have to do it differently
and I okay one wasn't wasn't the best
month
rooty eight will also win the apron so
let's just do this maybe it's not enough
to win that's possible comes around
before I cannot play I have no time
absolutely no time check they have to
may have to make the drum that's dry I
should have won that of course but okay
somewhere around here black is black is
toast but I couldn't really bring myself
can take on see and this should be
winning actually at our rookies success
of the engine goose right here I can
also take taking us strong
yeah I should have just taken it anyway
I'm going for one more game the bad
thing is if you are about to above 2500
drawing such a good play I mean it
really is strong just gives that clip it
points down so one more game
okay so I'm trying try for the game of
course but you said people are busy I'm
not sure that I want to play what I
guess
is playing but no idea disconnected now
it's not only more so she are looking
for a new game but game started
oh it so called yeah this is also one of
my tougher opponents but I beat him
earlier today so we all will see what
happens
however -1 score against which is
actually not that bad I had a much worse
score but yeah all from games where I
was in very good shape and then he yeah
he found some cool tactics that I didn't
that I didn't seem well
yeah this kind of stuff yeah this this
absolutely does not work but and you
still have to refute it yeah why does a
pawn up here and I would probably keep
it with Bishop g5 how to believe that
this should work so what's the dealy a
night before or something and I'd see
five maybe
okay let's prevent that before for the
moment let's see five I have thirsty for
some so I wanted to go Bishop g5 here
right just take this so that I can keep
the keep the pawn it's kind of normal
okay take this and now D for him keeping
the pawn so does he have compensation
for the pawn yeah
not enough maybe but something the the
bishop is strong I am maybe maybe he can
get the poem back in fact whom okay it's
not great okay
whoa isn't look to you one problem and
what what's the deal I don't to see it
well you see how about some sacrifice 93
and I don't I don't see it and what
happens an idea for a draw
okay metaphor a draw what a shame check
cannot play for a win here with King f3
it looks it looks like looks at it
suicidal
I have to check it no I came out playful
we knew cuz I offered check Gras I heard
game wrong no I don't think King f3 king
of three is probably just playing for
loss here I don't don't don't believe it
come in chess six takes it check this it
looks kind of a healthy check check
something like that looks it looks bad
it looks bad hmm yeah so maybe he has
another day as possible okay this is
what the computer once in a plane and
this is indeed better him I'm keeping
this keeping this bone tough anyway ah
below 2500 by one point but I think it
was a good session anyway I hope you
enjoyed the show having some very high
very high rated play here yeah okay guys
I'm back next week thanks for watching
bye bye